[Música]
hoy en directo a Vamos hasta la capital
estadounidense la fiscalía alega que el
expresidente Donald Trump habría violado
la ley de espionaje tras encontrar
documentos clasificados como Ultra
secretos en su residencia de Florida
para ampliar esta noticia conectamos con
Cristóbal Vázquez corresponsal de Franz
24 Cristóbal qué detalles se conocen de
los documentos encontrados
el FBI habría encontrado no solamente
documentos muy clasificados sino también
fotos información sobre el presidente de
Francia y otros documentos que estaban
en cerca de 20 cajas que retiró el lunes
de esta semana el FBI de la mansión del
ex presidente Donald Trump en la Florida
el objetivo principal de este
allanamiento de esta búsqueda fue
encontrar pruebas encontrar información
que terminan incriminando y dándole
argumentos al departamento de Justicia
sobre tres posibles crímenes que habría
incurrido el ex presidente Donald Trump
el primero de ellos fue haberse quedado
o destruido con información confidencial
que sacó de la Casa Blanca el segundo de
estos crímenes sería obstruir la
justicia porque durante más de un mes
archivos nacionales estaba pidiendo esta
información confidencial al ex
presidente y la justicia dice que no
terminó entregando la totalidad de los
documentos que le pidieron y en tercer
medida el crimen el acta de espionaje
que pues prohíbe quedarse con
información que comprometa la seguridad
Nacional de Estados Unidos este punto
preocupa mucho porque analistas dicen
que no sabe que no saben si el ex
presidente terminó compartiendo esta
información con otros asesores
información de seguridad nacional que
además medios como el Washington post
dicen que podría incluso Tener
información confidencial nuclear de
Estados Unidos que en un caso hipotético
podría haber terminado en manos de
terceros o de países adversarios a
Estados Unidos estas leyes de
comprobarse la culpabilidad podrían dar
hasta 10 años de cárcel por cada una de
estas leyes que se incumplió y que se
obstruyó Cristóbal hay un importante
debate sobre las consecuencias que
tendría este episodio en la vida
política del ex mandatario podría ser
inhabilitado para las elecciones de 2024
Sí y ya obviamente Donald Trump
reaccionó con unos
unas respuestas escritas diciendo que
esto era una una persecución que estaba
recibiendo por parte del FBI Y que
además expresidentes como Barack Obama
Pues también habían se habían llevado
información confidencial después de
haber terminado su periodo en la casa
blanca pero sí Precisamente en la
sección una sección de la ley en la que
si él en un expresidente no solamente se
queda sino que destruye información
confidencial y oficial del gobierno Esto
entonces no le permitiría al incumplir
esta ley de haberse quedado destruir
documentos oficiales ocupar un puesto de
cargo público un puesto Federal Esto
significaría entonces que Donald Trump
no podría entonces aspirar a la
presidencia en el 2024 como se viene
diciendo que lo va a hacer y que va a
ser el anuncio prontamente los
republicanos entonces lo que le están
diciendo al expresidente es que antes
esto ocurra pues anuncie su candidatura
para entonces proteger y brindarse
entonces de las consecuencias legales
que esto tenga sin embargo hay analistas
legales que están diciendo que esto
Simplemente no ocurriría porque hay
interpretación En la ley que en el caso
del ex presidente Donald Trump jugaría
su favor para que pueda presentarse como
candidato para el 2024